fake it seems say hi hey kit
see I don't say hi if I don't like you I
just don't I just don't see you oh so if
I [ __ ] you over in any kind of way
this is different you and I are friend
isn't matter let's suppose I did
something traumatic to you okay we're
coming soon we don't know each other
that well and you did something [ __ ]
up yeah like I yeah I fought it on your
girlfriend's face unbelievable I I get
right over it go ahead okay you would
get over it right away okay I feel like
I can't I don't I feel like I can do
whatever and you wouldn't be mad
probably you yeah if we weren't friends
and then you did something [ __ ] up to
me that's one thing yeah and then I
probably just wouldn't talk to you I'd
like that guy saw that about you you
I've you see the most racist yep
the craziest like I've never even had a
white person ever yeah that that and it
doesn't bother me
you're you look like Robert DeNiro to me
yeah he does that
what's crazy about it is I you know I
would think it was a big deal but he
does it on stage yes right so yeah if he
was just doing that like in the car or
behind you know if I didn't arrive it
he'd be scared yeah but he is like I'll
bring him up Anderson T is a good friend
I give you great intro you do give me
the best intros right huh and I'll go
he's the best comic in the country he
was on these shows his special is the
best I've ever seen
he's one of my best friends you know the
funniest guys in the country Andrew
Santino and Andrew walks up like this
will be Michael Haley yeah yeah and I
will do it every time I go you go
cackling yeah from the back yeah yeah
you guys I go yeah I go krepo rounder
more time for Bobby and I laugh so hard
and that's the thing is is that you know
is that racism it's not know if I it's
guys just hang around
it's tease you also do when you give me
intros yes it's French of you all
friends real friends he also does the
thing where he's like this redheaded
freak fire crotch loot you do you go on
fun rants where you should have yes you
[ __ ] do it what ever done that this
is so [ __ ] we call we can call someone
right now to value I say fire cross this
firehead disgusting yeah fire crock
what do I say you [ __ ] on but I like it
yeah by the way that's the that's the
deal if you do it in private
yeah I think you then you then it's
real hate and racism is real in private
yeah but if we joke to each other face
to face interesting you know what do we
say we ran into a we ran into someone we
know at at this restaurant we ate at
just today yeah and Bobby got weirded
out because I said if well well well if
it isn't the new Negro and Bobby's like
this oh my god and I was like oh so
that's the name of a TV show that he's
on call the new Negroes and of course
Bobby's like dude yeah I did that I
didn't that's what the show's called the
meet yes Candace is on a show called the
new Negro Comedy Central and really but
Bobby's face got I got and I hooked him
yeah he hugged I don't even know who he
was he hug him right away because he was
afraid that I great that I was being
raised oh my god how foolish do the show
smell the new Negro I didn't know that
[Music]